et bah dans un instant et politique
l'opposition doit-elle s'opposer
systématiquement face à face roger
karoutchi
robert rochefort habitudes
tin jusqu'à 14h le débat d'europe mehdi
on est très heureux de vous convier nous
sommes sur le stand des produits
laitiers en hall 1 au salon de
l'agriculture et on va parler politique
et vous pourrez réagir à tout moment
vous faites peut-être partie de ceux qui
rêvent d'une union nationale qui en
rêvait en tout cas il ya quelques mois
des citoyens des auditeurs qui
souhaitent un gouvernement capable de
réunir les meilleurs de se mettre
d'accord sur l'essentiel par exemple est
bien là au contraire le rejet du clivage
politique semble prendre fin la nature a
horreur du vide disent certains et pour
exister et bien l'ump a montré son
opposition il ya quelques jours à la loi
macron en réagissant à la procédure du
49-3 avec la motion de censure contre le
gouvernement
c'est un jeu politique sont surprises
espériez-vous au contraire autre chose
de la part de l'ump et de l'udf
notamment et bien aux deux débatteurs
vont s'opposer sur le sujet nous
accueillons ensemble robert rochefort
sous vos applaudissements économistes
député européen vice président du
mouvement démocrate et roger karoutchi
sénateur ump des hauts-de-seine vice
président de l'ump
messieurs la petite gageure c'est en une
minute de mettre sur la table vaut
première opinion avant d'entrer dans le
débat tous ensemble robert rochefort
pourquoi refusez-vous cette opposition
systématique et le rôle systématique
d'opposition que s'impose finalement
l'opposition
tout simplement parce que les français
en ont marre de ce jeu politique qu'il
ne fonctionne plus que notre système est
éculé que ça fait 35 ans que lorsque la
gauche est au pouvoir elle considère que
la droite est nulle lorsque la droite
est au pouvoir elle considère que la
gauche est nul et qu'il faut sortir de
cela mais attention wendy ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut considérer qu'il ya plus
de droite où il ya plus de gauche mais
lorsque il y a des choses que l'on peut
faire ensemble
et bien il ne faut pas hésiter à les
faire ensemble vous avez parlé de rome
macro le gouvernement s'est trompé sur
l'album accroc il nous a présenté sa
commune loi qu'elle est réglé tous les
problèmes
ce n'était pas le cas en revanche est ce
que si la loi macron avait été votée à
l'assemblée nationale l'opposition
aurait dû dire on vote contre moi je ne
le pense pas je ne pense pas d'ailleurs
quitte à voler valff aller voter pour
je pense qu'il fallait sable
nir une abstention constructive pour
dire bah finalement il ya certain nombre
de ces mesures qui sont des mesures
techniques qui sont bonnes pour la
société française
il faut au moins les laisser passer
voilà un exemple extrêmement concret je
leur donne un deuxième parce que vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure
regardez l'agriculture aujourd'hui
l'agriculture elle se décide en europe
elles se décident plus uniquement en
france elle oppose les pays d'europe du
nord qui volent des grandes fermes une
agriculture industrielle et les pays
d'europe du sud qui veulent conserver
une agriculture à visage humain avec des
exploitations familiales
vous croyez que ça ça oppose à droite et
la gauche en france non sur un sujet
comme celui là par exemple il faut se
rassembler parce que le combat il n'est
pas à paris son agriculture
il est à bruxelles sa député européen
qui vous le circonstances robert
rochefort alors on parlera d'agriculture
si vous souhaitez aussi roger karoutchi
mais vous me considérez que c'est utile
à certains égards est nécessaire même
que l'opposition sur rochefort confond
sectarisme et démocratie on peut
parfaitement être dans l'opposition
s'opposer au texte du gouvernement
faire des propositions écouter dialoguer
et être un opposant résolu ça ne veut
pas dire que sur certains sujets il faut
pas d'unité nationale c'est évident que
quand on dit à l'ump
unité nationale sur le terrorisme qui va
dire non unité nationale par rapport à
des ch qui va dire non évidemment que
c'est pas ça le sujet mais le sujet
c'est de dire aux français
quand vous votez ça a du sens
sinon ça n'a pas de sens ça a du sens de
dire il ya un programme projet une
philosophie de droite de gauche vous
choisissez un projet après que on puisse
parler au parlement
j'espère bien qu'on peut parler au
parlement heureusement qu'on peut parler
au parlement mais il faut pas dire non
non non il faut que tout le monde se
réunissent parce que c'est le meilleur
moyen de dire par exemple ce pas une
critique mais c'est comme ça que
marine le pen a raison de dire ump s
c'est tout pareil puisque toute façon
ils font tout ensemble
ça n'a pas de sens il faut des choses
intelligentes
ce que reprochent les français c'est pas
l'échec d'un système c'est pas l'échec
de deux dents d'un système
constitutionnel
c'est le manque de courage des
gouvernements de gauche et de droite
dans les années passées mais moi je suis
pour pied un gouvernement de droite avec
des idées sur les 35 heures sur les
services sociaux et qu'on avance alors
mais ça n'empêche pas de débattre en
débattre veut pas dire se rapprocher
faire du consensus mou pas de consensus
mou la france a besoin de réformes c'est
là pas besoin de consensus le sens des
convictions jours à venir robert
rochefort sur les propos à l'instant de
roger karoutchi quand on vote il faut
que ça ait du sens des biens choisis la
droite où les notions animé mais
regardez quel est le pays d'europe qui a
fait le plus de réformes c'est
l'allemagne
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que
madame merkel est une femme qui est un
consensus mou et qui est une femme molle
dans ses idées évidemment non et
pourtant c'est en allemagne que l'idée
des coalitions marche le mieux dans
énormément de lander et dans le
gouvernement fédéral également
aujourd'hui c'est le cas ça a été le cas
après monsieur fraudeurs lorsqu'il avait
fallu faire passer les grandes réformes
qui ont permis à l'allemagne de se
réformer et ben en allemagne le spd et
la cdu ou cs ou lorsqu'il le faut
travailler ensemble et je vous assure
que ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'ya plus
de droite qu'il n'y a plus de gauche en
france le problème c'est quoi le
problème c'est que regardez ce qu'a fait
le gouvernement de droite avant monsieur
hollande et monsieur hollande maintenant
comme ils sont dans une logique
strictement deux camps et bien c'est le
courant le plus dur de chacun des camps
qu'ils l'emportent
pourquoi nicolas sarkozy a perdu la
dernière fois probablement parce qu'il
sait marquer avec ce qu'on a appelé la
ligne buisson il s'est marqué très à
droite
il était très à droite dans l'idéologie
apparente françois hollande c'est pareil
en leader ni les français n'ont donc
plus besoin de belles images mais c'est
pas ça c'est pas ça c'est que
aujourd'hui l'idéologie comme ça qui est
illogique comme françois hollande qui se
fait élire au delà de ce qu'il pense lui
même et qui croît ensuite qu'au bout de
deux ans il va pouvoir devenir réalité
c'est un piège ça ne marche pas il ya
des conceptions politiques évidemment
mais le pragmatisme aujourd'hui c'est
plus importante l'idéologie croyez-vous
débattre mais c'est le règlement
sincèrement moi j'entends ce que dit
robert rochefort mais sincèrement non je
dis bien moi je suis de ceux qui sont
dans les débats au sénat pour trouver
des solutions des voies de passage c'est
donc je n'ai pas peur du consensus ça ne
me fait pas peur consensus mais il ya
des positions de départ
pardon de dire que la conception de la
gauche du monde du travail très encadré
très administrée n'est pas la mienne
plus libérale plus ouverte
quand je débats avec des gens de gauche
sur les 35 heures sur les seuils sociaux
sur le travail du dimanche je n'ai pas
la même conception que ça ne veut pas
dire que ensuite dans les débats on peut
pas avoir des positions qui se rapproche
et des positions qui sont dans l'intérêt
général
mais si on part du principe qu'il faut
par définition avoir des positions
communes sur pour tout et sur tous les
sujets parce que le pragmatisme c'est
bien mais le pragmatisme a une limite
c'est l'innovation c'est la vision de
l'avenir
le pragmatisme c'est du quotidien les
premières à 10 projets ni pour le projet
les dans les convictions un exemple en
la vision qu'on a cru et concret roger
karoutchi
la loi macro vous auriez pu à certains
égards la voter alors la loi macro moi
j'avais déjà dit d'ailleurs je me le
suis fait reprocher un peu dans mon camp
qu'il y avait des éléments de la loi
macron que j'étais prêt à voter et je
dis parfois en plaisantant que je vais
voter la loi
macron au sénat avec une nuance c'est
qu'évidemment elle va être totalement
réécrite au sénat et ce sera pas la loi
macron d'origine mais c'est pas la même
chose est la position majoritaire de
l'ump qui avait mérité il doit les
opposer
mais évidemment pas ce que l'on veut un
autre texte et si vous voulez pas avoir
un texte contre un contre un et sans
ouverture sur les 35 heures sans
ouverture sur les seuils sociaux sans
davantage de flexibilité pour les
entreprises
on va à la catastrophe voilà dites nous
si vous avez besoin clivage si le rôle
de l'opposition et de s'opposer aussi
faut sortir du dogmatisme du sectarisme
comme le disent certains nous avons
pierre ou aux 39 21 qui veut réagir
entre vous et face à bourgbarré sport et
roger karoutchi bonjour pierre on vous
écoute bien sûr votre position sur le
sujet quelle école alors effectivement
bon la gauche et la droite un petit
pense pas là cette opposition elle est
peut-être c'est bien sûr dans une
certaine mesure elle continue à l'être
mais elle est devenue cette dernière
venait un peu forme d'hémiplégie voyez
ce que je dis n'est plus immoral et
sociale où effectivement des uns et les
autres avec ses appartements forte
fini les parloirs des raisonnements qui
font table rase de ce qui s'est passé
l'an passé comment ça s'est opposé avec
une espèce de revers de manche un peu de
politique de terre brûlée pour un petit
côté dixon et quand ont repris quand on
fait presque la même chose mais avec une
autre façon d'amener les choses
bon je sais une caricature un petit peu
simple mais c'est un petit peu du jeu
enfantin d'avoir la primauté de faire la
chose qui prime sur la chose elle-même
je trouve que les politiques devraient
retrouver un peu d'humilité et profiter
des forces vives et des désavantages des
pensées de gauche et de droite ne pas en
faire du syncrétisme
mais en faire des compléments en enfer
défend de coopération alors oui je vais
je vais citer quelques exemples de ce
que vous dites les heures sup
défiscalisées la tva sociale les
conseillers territoriaux les peines
planchers la gauche a supprimé et dit
colin sarkozy promet aujourd'hui de
revoir les rythmes scolaires de revoir
la réforme des régions alors faire et
défaire c'est toujours travailler non
c'est plutôt ce que vous pensez il faut
absolument arrêter ce système absurde
qui fait que lorsqu'un ministre arrive
il considère qu'il faut qu'ils fassent
voter une loi à son nom qui est le
contraire de la loi de son prédécesseur
sur le même sujet et alors que la loi du
prédécesseur elle est même pas encore
rentrer en application et ainsi de suite
et c'est comme ça qu'on passe son temps
à voter des lois qui tricotent qui
détricote kir tricote ceci n'est prévue
lé syndicat vient alors je voudrais dire
à roger karouchi juste une chose c'est
que moi je parle pas de consensus je
parle de compromis ce qui n'est pas la
même chose c'est-à-dire fait quand on
sait non c'est pire
non non c'est pas pire des cas
absolument pas absolument bien regarder
parce que vous regardiez aujourd'hui
c'est vrai moi je crie fort parce qu'il
ya quelques il y avait quelques
auditeurs potentiels 20 mai il ya
quelques vaches qui passe de choses à
faire à côté des studios concernés mais
attendez si on étend d je voulais juste
non mais attendez vous me déstabiliser
je me mets à m mais vous voyez bien que
il faut arriver à 2 l'efficacité et puis
quand aux français les français il faut
savoir les français changent d'avis
aussi les français il veut y votent pour
nicolas sarkozy puis vote pour françois
hollande
et puis voteront pour un autre donc ça
veut dire que les français eux mêmes
c'est pas des girouettes ils sont pas à
droite d'un seul coup et à gauche de
l'autre et ils cherchent à charnay
rebondir quelque chose merci c'est à
dire vers voudrait le meilleur de l'info
promis vous dit non mais ça des astros
suis pas d'accord du tout robert
rochefort découvre la lune il nous dit
les gens ils ont voté sarkozy dont voter
hollande et voteront pas noc
mais c'est ça la démocratie heureusement
qu'on leur revient c'est fatigant et
quand même par faire quand même
ce sont les citoyens qui choisissent
dans ce pays et le jour où vous dirais
que ça n'est plus le cas parce qu'il
faut trouver des solutions uniformes ça
voudra dire qu'on l'ait dessaisie du
suffrage universel
les liens sont anciens et ça il en est
même pas question non la vérité c'est
que ce que dit robert rochefort ça
renvoie plus à la manière de faire la
loi que aux oppositions politiques moi
j'ai des ministes deux ans et demi je
vous rassure j'ai pas voulu de loi mon
nom et j'ai pas cherché à en avoir
nous avons le temps des rats exagérons
rien mais au delà de ça c'est plutôt le
fait que dorénavant il faut faire la loi
pas seulement avec le conseil d'état
avec les cabinets ministériels mais en
lien avec les syndicats les associations
les représentants des professions il
faut regarder au niveau économique
comment on fait mais une bonne loi
elle peut être de gauche elle peut être
de droite ça c'est vrai mais c'est pour
vous une série las la réalité c'est que
il faut bien qu'elles soient inspirées
par une philosophie celle accordée car
l'orientation éteindre une des portes
karotz un point de départ et ses forces
après moi je suis je suis député
européen et vous savez comment
fonctionne l'europe
donc il n'ya pas une loi en europe qui
peut passer si elle n'est pas votée par
initiative de gauche et une partie de la
droite
leur initiative de droite et la
démocratie européenne et plus loire
seulement par une loi que la nuit la
commission européenne aujourd'hui
monsieur juncker qui est de droite qui
doit travailler avec monsieur moscovici
que de gauchy pour sortir du problème de
la grèce dont j'espère qu'on va en
sortir aujourd'hui ou demain
eh bien vous avez un gouvernement de
gauche voire d'extrême gauche d'ultra
gauche qui est confronté à quoi à des
ministres autour de la table enfin
compris mecs aiment surfer
le compromis permanent au niveau
européen je l' ai connu j'ai été député
européen
c'est souvent un compromis a minima et
c'est souvent un compromis inapplicable
et si aujourd'hui beaucoup de citoyens
français ont une position de rejet par
rapport à l'europe c'est que parfois et
vous croyez que les français sanctionnés
fonctionnaires inquiets rejettent le
compromis roger karoutchi vous lisiez on
a besoin aussi de savoir pour qui on a
voté avec les politiques appliquées en
l'espèce mais il sur facebook nous dit
attention je crains que cette pseudo
guerre droite gauche ne fasse que
renforcer le front national non mais je
suis d'accord il s'agit pas de faire une
guerre droite gauche
il faut avoir sa conception en
reconnaissant en admettant en tolérant
celle des autres c'est pas la guerre la
démocrate mais la motion de censure et
c'est un sympa non mais on en arrive à
sa gauche le gouvernement de gauche ne
voulait pas que sa loi passe avec des
votes de droite et du centre non ici se
souvient de gauche avaient le sentiment
qu'ils avaient 40 frondeurs qui nous est
que malgré les voix de droite ça
suffirait pas je signale que le 49-3
vous devriez nous féliciter pendant la
période 2007-2012 mal classé mais vous
avez raison mais moi ça ne me choquerait
pas qu'il y ait des lois qui soit votée
par une majorité aux affaires monsieur
avec un groupe de députés de cette
majorité qui ne votent pas pour mais un
groupe du camp d'en face qui veut
le gouvernement n'a pas voulu pour la
loi macron allez on se retrouve
messieurs sur l'opposition et le rôle de
l'opposition est il de systématiquement
s'opposer en tout cas d'afficher une
ligne claire pour ceux qui ont voté pour
un parti c'est l'opinion de roger
karoutchi face à robert rochefort
partisans n'ont pas du consensus mou non
mais c'est bon pour lui
on l'a entendu alors je vais sûrement
voir les bains je vous donne la parole
dans un instant une petite minute et
c'est à peu près tout
l'europe en europe un repli dit
14 heures en direct en public on sort au
salon de l'agriculture venez passer on
est là revendique ardeurs encore sur ce
débat le rôle de l'opposition est
systématiquement de s'opposer débat
politique quelques jours après la motion
de censure déposée par l'ump à nous
avons roger karoutchi sénateur ump des
hauts-de-seine qui maintient que il faut
que une fois le vote passé notre vote
notre idéologie est un sens vous avez
choisir un projet il faut donc que
droite et gauche et bien s'organise en
fonction
pour robert rochefort député européen
vice-président du modem et bien ce jeu
est éculée il faut en sortir sans
considérer pour autant qu'il n'y a ni
droite ni gauche
messieurs vous êtes rejoint en studio
par un auditeur mais si vous avez la
parole
on vous écoute dans ce délicieux bonjour
je sais bien que vous avez beaucoup
d'humour vous donc monsieur karoutchi
donc je vous posais une première
question à base du mot j'ai rencontré le
numéro trois du medef qui disait voilà
monsieur hollande a fait des réformes
que sarkozy n'aurait jamais rêvé de
faire ou penser faire donc je me pose la
question l'avenir est ce que le prochain
gouvernement de droite va nous faire du
hollande ou du mélange donc c'est
mélenchon ça va être dur mais met donc
la réaction c'est en manque de
visibilité sur le terrain et la réalité
au bout je pense à une société qui
s'appelle la société de seuils s'occupe
de dentelle 100 salariés
ils vont tout perdre peut-être dans deux
mois parce qu'il manque juste des gens
pour financer leurs activités
il ya des gens des financiers qui disait
vous avez des projets géniaux à faire
mais il manque le gap on est encore en
crise et pendant ce temps là on voit
d'une part des gens qui se chamaillent
certes il faut c'est faire la politique
c'est beau mais d'un autre côté on voit
aussi le fn et la politique du ni ni
donc on peut on est en perte de
visibilité qu'est ce que vous en pensez
tous les deux héros shirodhara remercie
mais sincèrement je suis pas de ceux qui
disent que les chamailleries sur des
écrans c'est bien moi je suis pour
justement qu'on change les méthodes de
travail et à l'assemblée au sénat parce
que je considère que c'est pas une bonne
image
il faut des députés des sénateurs
présents dans les hémicycles qui
débattent sérieusement qu'ils avancent
des idées pas qui se dispute parce que
les français ne supportent pas ça paye
pas ces gens pour disputer dans tout le
monde il est paye pour travailler donc
là dessus c'est pas sur la chamaillerie
sur le reste vous dit
hollande a fait des réformes que sarko
n'a pas fait beau oui parce que sur dans
un texte de loi et quand vous avancez
il ya forcément des éléments de la même
manière en 2017 qui a des choses
j'entendais robert rochefort dire à ben
vous allez tout changer non c'est pas le
sujet moi j'ai déjà dit que par exemple
puis si je participe en tant que faire
se peut aux projets présidentielle de
2017 je dirais qu est-ce qu on garde on
parce qu'il ya des choses à garder
qu'est-ce qu'on rejette parce que ça ne
marche pas la différence c'est pas de
dire il faut un compromis c'est de dire
regardons ce qui marche fort
nicolas chose qui fonctionne 7 dont au
niveau économique a pas grand chose qui
fonctionne mais il ya des éléments de
réforme qui ont été faits depuis deux
ans et demi que l'on gardera on va mal
tout jeter à la poubelle
bon le manichéisme politique français
est un des freins à la réforme c'est
benoist apparu député ump qui dit il a
raison il a raison robert au choix et
vous traduisez monsieur en studio le
ras-le-bol sur ces chamailleries
politiques qui qui qui qui nous mène à
la perte non sur twitter nous dit la
france en crève de ces postures
politiques que ce soit de droite ou de
gauche puisque ça vient du camp d'en
face je ne vote pas
c'est de la politique d'un autre siècle
bien sûr alors pour aller dans le sens
de l'humour de notre auditeur tout à
l'heure oui c'est vrai que vous avez des
fois à la buvette de l'assemblée
nationale ou ailleurs vous avez un
député de l'opposition qui dit au type
de la majorité bon dp choix de faire ça
parce que nous on pourra pas le faire ou
réciproquement et et on le sait bien que
ça se passe aussi comme ça donc il faut
évidemment arriver à être beaucoup plus
constructif et puis parce que il faut
bien voir qu'on est confronté à des
problèmes qui sont les mêmes je prends
un exemple simple la démographie le fait
que l'allongement de la durée de la vie
soit là c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est
un constat absolue eh ben ça modifie le
système de retraites il faut l'assumer
et il faut sur la question des retraites
on arrête de considérer qu'il y aurait
une solution de droite en retraite qui
serait la solution de droite une
solution de gauche qui serait solution
des retraites il faut trouver quelque
chose qui respecte les équilibres qui
fasse comprises en moyenne plus
longtemps mais préserve qui préserve des
jeux termine jeu je termine juste qu'ils
préservent comment dire en même temps là
or social de ce qu'est la question des
retraites c'est des questions comme ça
il y en à vous savez il y en a cinq ou
six alors un mot simplement son côté si
on en fait oui mais mais le modem
justement parce que le modem pense que
c'est pas du tout seul qui peut y
arriver c'est évidemment avec d'autres
et vous allez poser la question du front
national et le front national a plaidé
vient vite vous bien que le front
national avait il
il prospère justement sur cette question
là non héhéhé moi je ne crois pas que le
mps ça c'est un jargon du front national
que vous m'entendrez jamais utilisée oui
mais en même temps ils prospèrent sur ce
jeu de rôle bien sûr cette façon de 100
points 0,3 est dans la façon il est posé
vous la rejeter au modem c'est une belle
philosophie j'ai l'impression que les
français sont d'accord en masse avec ça
et pour autant vous êtes un parti
minoritaire à droite ça veut dire que
fait valoir cécile de la patrouille ne
vous répond que non
il se trouve que je vous ramène jalousie
dire tout à l'heure sur l'allemagne la
france la france est victime
non la france est fictive d'un système
politique dans lequel il n'y a pas de
proportionnelle et donc à cause de cela
à chaque fois qu'un président est élu il
a une chambre bleue ou une chambre rose
et donc il n'ya pas aussi calme en
attendant il n'y a pas de légende et mes
recherches et leur chasse m'embarque en
allemagne mais non en allemagne s'est
complètement le contraire en allemagne
il ya une proportionnelle c'est là faut
toujours qu'il faut toujours j'ai
quarante réformes et ce n'est pas le
ressort se trompe complètement sur le
système de retraites c'est pas le
problème de savoir que l'analyse est
différente c'est la même à gauche et à
droite on sait bien qu à l'allongement
de la vie
on sait bien qu'à moins d'actifs on sait
bien qu'à des difficultés système de
retraite
le problème c'est un problème de courage
politique c'est de savoir qui va dire
aux français il faut travailler plus
longtemps
il faut travailler plus si vous voulez
car vous conservez les mêmes droits à
retraite c'est la chose le courage
politique pas leur dire que charmed
je suis d'accord mais le courage
politique c'est autre chose que le
compromis parce que pouvez dire ce que
vous voulez un moment
on fait le procès l'a plutôt des
majorités sans courage des gouvernements
sans ampleur sans vision mais la vérité
c'est que lorsque le général de gaulle
était là il a fait des réformes
profondes et elle était si semblement
communiste moi je parlais la sainte
catherine et où le général de gaulle pas
qu'un bout quelquefois je prends tout du
général de gaulle les français
aujourd'hui
et bien ça y est encore une fois
l'opposition a joué son rôle
d'opposition le la loi macro ça sera
tricoter de son côté par la gauche vous
reviendrai sur les réformes
on a l'impression d'un balancier et
bernard nous dit et finalement est ce
qu'on n'est pas pris à notre propre
piège avec l'alternance qu'on espère
toujours pour changer d'idée et changer
d'air la loi macro pardon de vous dire
si le gouvernement utiliser le 49-3
c'est qu'une partie importante du parti
socialiste ne voulait pas de cette loi
et c'est pas parce que c'est de tenir
comme certainement d'accord qu'on peut
ne rien faire aussi mais naturelle
attendait mais la réalité elle est dans
la profondeur du débat et dans
l'engagement des français
ce qu'il faut c'est que les grands
partis d'alternance est une capacité à
faire des projets auxquels les français
adhèrent ce qui se passe en ce moment et
quand on parle du fn etc
c'est qu'on a le sentiment à droite
comme à gauche qu'on ne fait plus rêver
et espérer les français c'est ça le
drame
et s'il faut un grand projet pour 2017
c'est pas de savoir s'il va tout casser
de ce qu'a fait la gauche c'est de
savoir comment il va faire adhérer les
français un projet sur ce projet
évidemment il faut un projet il fasse
adhérer nous avons antoine qu'ils
appellent de toulon qui veut réagir à ce
que vous dites messieurs aux 39 21 beaux
jours antoine la parole j'entends depuis
tout à l'heure parler de courage
politique de monsieur karoutchi très
belles paroles mais je crois que il faut
passer il faut passer aux actes mois
bien sûr que comme beaucoup de français
je comprends plus j'accepte plus cette
opposition stérile ou alors une majorité
qui finalement se dit voilà sur la
majorité j'ai forcément raison donc ça
c'est vrai que c'est un système qui
marche plus mais là je crois que au delà
de présenter un projet 2017 et ses
terrains 3 qu' il ya vraiment pas de la
part des citoyens parce que nous les
citoyens mais on a beaucoup de bon sens
et il en est très clair avec nous mêmes
par contre au niveau des politiques
je crois qu'ils en ont vraiment besoin
d'une remise en question très importante
et de se dire tout simplement que
aujourd'hui moi ça me fait mal au coeur
de voir des personnes à tout devienne
député ou maire ou conseiller général ou
autre part uniquement une personne
inscrite sur 10 c'est un drame mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya vraiment
besoin de te retourner dans le citoyen
et les airs ou politique on se remet en
question et on va faire de la politique
autre discours que vous tenez antoine
roger milla est par exemple moi j'ai
voté un dd loi présenté par la gauche
depuis que je suis revenu au sénat sur
la sécurité sur certain nombre de sujets
sur le renseignement sur l'immigration
ça vous allez voter clairement joué oui
parce que dans le fond vous dans une
année parlementaire
vous avez trois quatre textes très
politique mais vous avez beaucoup de
textes qui sont en réalité de gestion ou
d'intérêt général sur ces textes de
gestion d'intervalle évidemment que
voulaient voter là où il ya opposition
ferme
c'est sur des textes qui ont une
philosophie politique très marqué au fer
rouge par que des mois je crois que
notre pays va pas bien la crise est
absolument forte et on n'est pas du tout
en train d'en sortir aussi vite que le
gouvernement peut le prétendre
il va falloir faire des efforts des
réformes absolument considérable et la
question c'est de savoir si la classe
politique mis au pouvoir aura le courage
de faire ces réformes
moi je vous dis que si on ne change pas
le jeu politique la classe politique
n'aura jamais le courage de les faire
ces réformes parce qu'elle sera tout de
suite piégé par cette logique de la
droite contre la gauche de la gauche
contre la droite donc il faut un
rassemblement beaucoup plus large que
l'idée simplement d'un seul camp pour
réussir à faire ces réformes dans notre
pays a besoin
je prends rendez vous avec vous c'est
une question d'histoire c'est pas une
question d'échéance de la prochaine
élection s'inspirer du mode de
fonctionnement proportionnelle du
parlement européen le mode de
fonctionnement du parlement européen il
n'a pas donné que de bons résultats
publics fonctionnent bien
s'il y a des partis politiques dignes de
ce nom avec des projets et pas seulement
des ambitions personnelles moment ne
fonctionne pas très bien et bien 50% de
leur vendée au bassin
on n'est pas là pour faire de l'analyse
on est là pour faire bouger les mains
sûres merci beaucoup
roger karoutchi sénateur ump merci à
vous robert rochefort député européen
vice-président du modem